if you had to be beaten or you had to
listen to people being tortured
i know this is a terrible question but
it speaks to
the intensity of listening to people
being tortured which of those was more
torturous
listening absolutely no question asked
why
yes because
when they start beating me
okay i a lot of anxiety
and a lot of inside pain goes away
because my body is weak
and the problem is to have like strong
body and destroyed soul
because somehow the soul and body has to
be balanced out so
if you like if you threat
threaten me
and then you put me in a situation
especially you have power over me put me
in a situation that is so painful and i
i'm eating myself from inside
but when you
beat me
and then you cause me pain
and that pain
this is horrible to say but it's good
for to
because it weakens my
the sharpness of my mind to
to process
the perceived pain that i may be
receiving
[Music]
i'm speaking today with muhammad ul
salahi born december 21 1970 who spent
14 years in guantanamo bay without being
charged arriving august 4th 2002
released october 17 2016.
he wrote a memoir in 2015 while still
imprisoned the us government
declassified it in 2012 with numerous
redactions
it was the first work by a still
imprisoned guantanamo guantanamo
detainee
published in 2015 became a international
bestseller it details salahi's
experience of being force-fed sea water
sexually molested subjected to a mock
execution repeatedly beaten kicked and
smashed across the face
and all spiced with threats that his
mother would be brought to guantanamo
and gang raped
prison officials prevented salahi from
receiving a copy of his published book
the mauritanian a film adaptation of the
memoir was released on february 12th
this year directed by kevin mcdonald and
starring jody foster to hire rahim
benedict cumberbatch and shailene
woodley he's been living in mauritania
since his release he reattained his
passport last year and has been
attempting to gain permission to travel
not least to germany to see his son
thank you so much for inviting me today
in your program
and i feel truly honored to
talk to you and to your
audience
my name is muhammad
i come from mauritania
[Music]
i was born in the south my father was a
camel herd
i don't know any father of mine who
wasn't
a camel heard of sort
and
i
my dream was to
grow to be a camel herder just like my
father
but this dream was cut short because of
the successive
drought
that hit the country in the 70s and the
80s
so all our camels
died out so died i mean and we had only
very few that couldn't sustain the life
of a big family
so
we are
12 siblings
from the same father and same mother
so my mother decided single-handedly to
move
the family against the will of my father
near the city for the children to find
jobs
and just to make a livelihood because my
father was hanging on a dream
that would never materialize so he was
living in this fantasy that
he he could recuperate but
that's how many how many camels did your
father have and you were living in a
rural area at that point obviously
yes
so
i heard
so when i the the thing i remember it's
like a dozen
a little bit over a dozen
and then they became fewer and fewer so
when my father died when i was
we had only like
several maybe three four
and then
how did you survive i mean how is it
possible for a family of that size to
survive
with that limited supply of livestock
what else was the family doing in order
to keep
to keep everything together
so my father my mother decided that the
kids need to abandon this lifestyle and
find jobs in the cities so my oldest
brother
went to senegal across the border
we were just at the border southern
border to senega and
i was
seven
at that time
this was 78
and then the other kids found the shop
at bakeries and just to make ends meet
so we have the same plate so we all
contribute
they couldn't find the job for me
because i was very weak and very small
and then the second best thing they sent
me to school
and it was by accident and i didn't have
a birth certificate so
they i we went to the school the
principal said he doesn't have birth
certificate but i accept him
and i want you to give a birth
certificate that's why you see my birth
certificate
has different like
birth dates sometime no birthday
sometime
31st sometime 21st sometime 1-1 so
anyway and then i fell in love with
school
because i just loved it
and i remember this very
hot day
very hot when we say hot in mauritania
it's really hot
and the school was
i just went the other day and i measured
the distance it was about two kilometers
that is over one mile
and
and i used to walk this
distance back and forth twice a day
because we have the
the
morning
class from 8 to 12 and the eve the
afternoon class from 3
to 5.
so meaning i work every day at least
eight kilometers
about six miles every day
and
and i didn't have shoes
and i remember
running
and then my feet burn
like beyond
the description
then i would go to
structures
and the few trees to cool them down
and then on my way this
our neighbor which was like
doing well
she stopped me and starts calling me
telling me why didn't you wear your
shoes
and then start started telling me this
is really bad and you should always wear
your shoes and i was burning she was
talking to me and i was burning and i
was too ashamed jordan to tell her
that i didn't have money to buy shoes my
family was so poor we just came from
the countryside
and
and she just kept scolding me so i
agreed
to go back
to
my home
and then pretend that i wear shoes but
instead
i took another route where i avoid
avoiding this woman that's how we did
it's like
i rarely ate meat because i didn't have
money
and so
but i did well in school even though
like my family never asked me
how i did
they didn't even understand the concept
of
passing from one class to the next were
you the only sibling who who went to
school
yeah yes me and
the older one so
and what kind of education what kind of
education did your parents have
aside from bedouin education none
so bedouin education where you learn how
to read to write
or like homeschooling
which is automatic when i went to school
i know how to read and drive because
that's
because we were
like a book tribe
you know
a tribe that you know
because you have in mauritania like the
tribes that carry weapons and the tribe
that carried the books so we carried the
books
and what's the distinction between those
two what what's the distinction between
those tribes i mean obviously books and
weapons but i've never heard that
distinction drawn before so what does
that mean exactly
so it means it's like
kind of a caste systems that this
disappeared but i saw it in my lifetime
so some tribes
carry weapons
and
like
build this emirate like
they collect taxes
and they provide
security
and they like
protect the borders
and some tribes they don't carry weapons
they just carry the books and then they
take this religious leadership where
they like
organize religious ceremony like
marriage
like
divorce like uh jurisprudence
like kind of a
inofficial judiciary okay and so there's
no separation between those functions in
some sense and and having the books and
what books what what are the
characteristic books
yes so
what we learn is mostly like the grammar
arabic grammar
and the greek
philosophy
and religion
quran
and the tradition what we call hadith
and that's it that's the extent of it no
languages
etc etc and what's the greek philosophy
and you said that was taught at home
yes all of it
and and so what did you learn about
greek philosophy it seems like a rather
strange intermingling so how does that
come about the mixture of of greek
philosophy and education according to
the quran let's say
well jordan
so i didn't i didn't advance in this
home schooling to get to greek
philosophy because you have to be
old enough so the islamic jurisprudence
is based on
what they call uh
osun
and the soul is derived from
uh from greek philosophy so the whole
jurisprudence is derived from
the logic of the greeks and we have
always this discussion that in order to
modernize our jurisprudence islamist
buildings we have to learn leibniz and
we have to learn about einstein rapturon
descartes because the greek philosophy
on which this whole islamist province is
built
is outdated obviously
and
so
so okay so back to your schooling so you
you came into the city you couldn't find
a job specifically so you were sent off
to school what and what kind of school
was that what did you learn there and
and was it like a standard classroom
that the sort of in a standard western
classroom how was it organized and what
did you learn
so it was a french
school system
that we the government inherited from
the french colonial time
and
and it was just different than the
school system
i'm used to at home because
at home
i can learn at my own pace
and there are no tests
you know you just learn what you want
and then for as long as you want
which was
much more advanced and much more better
for me
but the school system it was so much the
french school system
so much pressure so i had like
very strict uh curriculum and i have to
go with it even though
if it's like quicker i have
to keep pace
and if it's like too slow i have to wait
so i cannot
like uh learn with my own pace
and so
and i did well actually so i was always
number one until i graduated
never was i number two
and i
used like what i learned at home
you know
and it was a big advantage for me
and uh
so and as soon as i finish high school
i
received
a scholarship from germany
you know and this is like wild i mean
right
yeah did you even know what it meant at
that point to receive a scholarship from
germany
no
it was all all by accident pure accident
because
i really wanted to go to france because
i i loved like france because there is
so much advertisement
and i watch like french tv
i
uh why i like french music like
what's her name
[Music]
it's pf
yes yeah
yes it is
yeah
it's a great movie made of edf life it's
a brilliant movie yes yeah so i want
france this is all advertisements you
know and the magazines so i want to go
to france but
i did did you enjoy the french school
did you enjoy the french school system
or was it was it hard on you you did
well so
what was it like as an experience
i enjoyed a lot
but
you know i enjoyed i went to two schools
at the same time so i went to the
traditional koran school
and the french school
i went to the koran school because i
loved the friendship in the mosque you
know like what you would call in canada
sunday school i don't know whether you
have it but americans always talk about
it so i love this sunday school because
i have so much freedom so i can do
whatever i want and there is no pressure
whatsoever
and ironically the thing i learned in
the
in the
sunday school
i mean
in the
mask
i retained them to this day because i
chose to learn them
you know
and
and in the french school yes there was
like some kind of pressure especially
during the test
i don't like tests i think tests are the
worst thing that the western
civilization
has come up with i don't think this are
horrible why should i test anyone if you
don't want to learn something just don't
learn it you know
and
if if i was responsible for the system
in my country i would do away
my first day with test
notice
you just learn as you want and if you
are a doctor you just go to the hospital
and work in the hospital your senior
doctors will and would know whether you
are qualified or not if you are
a
computer engineer you just go find
someone to
show them what you learn and then they
will
give you a job and they will see whether
you can do the job or not because test
is not indicative of anything well you
you had you had intrinsic motivation
obviously and you loved to learn so
it was probably superfluous for you to
have the pressure added so you got a
scholarship to germany what happened as
a consequence
so
it was 1988
i was only 70.
and it was the first time any member of
my family ever traveled abroad
aside from senegal senegal is just
is very close
it was the first time any member of my
family ever boarded a plane
it was you know it was amazing and
i remember
when the
plane took off i was frantically reading
quran because i memorized the quran to
this day i know every single page
and
this
student who already went to france said
are you scared
i i didn't know my answer what was my
answer but actually i was scared
but i'm sure i told him i wasn't scared
well it's not surprising i mean first of
all you were on a plane for the first
time and you're not familiar with him
and then you're going to a completely
foreign country and no one in your
family has ever done that and tell me
about the tribe you said you were from
again from the from the tribe that that
was focused on books what's the tribal
organization it's beyond the family
obviously what what does it look like
so a tribe
is kind of
a small country
like the tribe
a tribe is a family name so
you have your tribe that's your family
so if you are sick
they will provide you
if you get in trouble
with another tribe they will go to the
tribe and they they will make peace
if there is money that needs to pay
they would pay
the money let's say if you kill someone
you know by mistake
so
your tribe will pay for the other the
family who lost that person
you know
as like a kind of insurance
and i always say in mauritania we should
adopt this
tribal system
but the country should be one single
tribe just like in canada canada is a
big tribe
because
the
canadian state is the one that provides
you with health insurance
they have set up
insurance damage insurance
to pay
and if you kill someone by mistake your
insurance space i.e your tribe
and i think that the best way i could
describe what the tribe
i think it's
how many people would would compose the
tribe that you belong to how large was
it
about
i really i don't have any scientific
number
but i would say when i was growing up i
would
like
randomly say hundred thousand
and how many tribes are there in
mauritania do you know a lot a lot of
tribe uh in all
shape and form not only the warrior
tribe you have the warrior tribe you
have
the book
tribe i.e zawaya and you have the
almost serving tribes like the tribe who
provide services
like
art artists this is like almost
independent tribe and all they do is
just like entertain entertainment
and you have
unfortunately i have to admit we had
slaves
they just like served you know you own
them and they serve you
in i think 81 this was abolished you
know but we need to face up to this
horrific past
and
just well we all have a lot of horrific
past to face up to
yes so unfortunately
yes unfortunately well hopefully we can
do better that's the plan right so all
right so you got on the plane and you
read the quran on the plane and you made
it to germany you must it's no wonder
you were afraid i mean what did you
think was waiting for you
so i had no clue you know i like
surprises because when i i was sitting
like with
one of the people in the studio and then
someone asked me so what are you going
to talk to
jordan about i said i have no clue
[Laughter]
and then he said
and
i said i don't care
whatever
and i like surprises and i i'm very
curious you know just like you
and
and so we arrived in paris because i had
to change the
there was no direct flight to frankfort
so i changed the
the first thing i saw in paris
and i'm ashamed to say this
everything was clean
and everybody was wearing very tight
clothes
and
everything was in place and the women
were wearing very nice clothes
everything was
and
of course that was the impression later
on i
i
i noticed that the clothes are really
not very comfortable you know for some
reason because the booboo and the
african loose clothes
were worn for a reason
and
so i took my plane i had
i had
i had in my pocket about
12 dollars 12 or 13
that the money that my family gave to me
as a pocket money
12 or 13
and
18 fran uh franks
80 francs
and
so i took my plane and we arrived like
11 p.m
at in frankfort
i did not speak english
i did not speak german
so
i came there
and then they stamped my passport
and then for some reason with jessie
everything they showed me
the hotel where i spent the night
and then it was sheraton
for the first time jordan i sat
in a room alone
and that was very scary because my
family was big
my family was very loud
and every time at every moment someone
is watching you
right so you were alone for the first
time in a foreign country where you
didn't speak the language
yes and alone physically with no one yes
right right i understand and that was
very scary to me
and because
i
i in in a very weird way my privacy was
defined by the people around me because
they were my cocoon
you know because i trust them i'm not
afraid of them i could do everything
in front of them but now i'm alone
it was like the people i'm used to we
are filled with ghosts
but i'm afraid of ghosts
and then
i took a shower and i did like just
everyone i love the towels i love the
small teeny tiny soup
i stole
i stole everything i put it in my bag
that was my first
theft
and
so
i i fell asleep watching
german tv i didn't understand anything
and then a friend of mine who came with
me whose family is
a little bit richer and they used to go
to paris not him
he came knocked at my door said muhammad
no we can eat for free this is a hotel i
said really
i said yes he took me
to the
elevator last night i took elevator but
i was so tired i didn't pay attention to
this
like miracle
you know something that small room
that you get into and then
then it stops
it's very disorientating because i
didn't know how many stairs i made
up and down
and then i went to this buffet very huge
with a lot of people
white people european people
by and large
and i'm a small bedouin
and then there was everything eggs
all types of bread uh marmalade
uh all kinds of things but
this was
the proverbial german
de qual der val
the torture of too many choices
i
only use
two
in mauritania tea and bread
and when we were like
doing really good
they give me butter in my bread and
marmalade really good stuff
so this always knew and i was telling
myself i need to eat something because i
would look foolish and i would look
straight if i don't eat something
then i choose eggs because i know how to
eat eggs or at least i thought
and then
i sat there
i felt like everything everyone was
looking at me everyone put everything
down
and i was the scene and then i broke the
eggs it was not cooked very well and i
hate half cooked eggs
and
we say in mauritania
we say in mauritania i found myself
with a thorny twigs between my legs
so
i couldn't move
forward
and neither did could i move backward
and so
i i thought i need to get out of this
place
and then i
i hit the egg somewhere
and
i i drink that it was horrible it was
lifted i hate lifting you know
you know
i love my tea being very well cooked and
very well brewed
you know because this is tasteless to me
like you know a bag you put it in hot
water there is no
no taste to it then so all that food you
got half cooked eggs and bad tea
[Laughter]
talking about bad luck
and then we took the plane to the city
of zarbriken
at the border of the senegal very close
to uh
very close to mets anonymous strasbourg
and
and so we took a small plane and because
a small plane was really very
wobbly i thought god want to punish me
now this spirit is going to crash
because i stole
the soap from the hotel
and then i was really so i was like
praying frantically and i promised
myself
i took it upon myself never to steal
anything anymore
you know if i survived this very
bumpy ride
and we arrived at zarbriken i started
the language i studied
and i graduated in telecommunication
microelectronics a few years later
and that how many years how many years
did you study there
i stayed in germany
12 years i studied and i worked so
and you picked up german and english
there or just german when you were there
yes german i picked english
mostly in prison
so okay what happened in germany
what happened you studied you got your
degree and what was it was it a
technical what what you what what
educational institute was it that you
attended
i attended uh
i will say the name it's very long very
boring gerhard mercator
university of duisburg
now it's called
university of duisburg essen
and i studied
microelectronics
telecommunication that is a very fancy
way to say that you can program and you
can like
set up computer networks
and
and how did you choose how did you
choose that how did you choose your
course of study
peer pressure
i wanted to be a pilot
and but
i had problems
during my first year
and my friends told me that this is
useless because in mauritania back then
we had a fleet of two
airplanes in whole mauritania two
airplanes
and this is only like
rich kids they could go and fi and make
this pilot license
and i wouldn't have a job they said the
future is like
micro electronics and so and
i just wanted to study that because my
friends told me that and how did you
make friends there and how long did it
take you and and what was your family
how are you communicating with your
family
yeah we didn't have what's up i can't
tell you that much
and like we only had this
phone
but we didn't have a phone at home so i
had to call my brother at work
and tell him that i'm doing well
and then he relayed the message to the
family because he didn't have a phone at
home
that was in the early 90s
and were you lonesome were you excited
like how was your life when you got to
germany
you know
i was you know most of the time i was
very depressed because of the cold
and
because of the cold
because of the call
you know
and
you know i went through a lot of
depression because of
you know my
you know germany is a lot of very
they are very
very
distinct look to them
and i looked different and that did not
help me a lot general people are very
nice people but whenever i went to
places and so especially when i travel
back and forth
they always put me on special screening
and i hated myself and
you know i was very young and i always
looked in the mirror said
you know i'm really a very very bad
person because why did they pick me
from all those people you know
and so what did you make of that what
was your explanation for that i mean you
said you thought you were a bad person
it was was there
but did you experience you said that the
germans were nice people but that but
you talked about this screening so did
you experience other forms of treatment
that made you feel that way or was it
primarily the the airport screening
not only also when you look for a job
you know during the year
the
like vacation they always prefer like
native german which i mean i kind of
understand
but
this all like i'm not giving any value
judgment to any of this jordan i'm just
telling you how i felt
i felt
i have i had very
low self-esteem
and then i started
to completely neglect myself neglect
like what i wear what which made the
things
was it loans was it because you were
alone i mean you know you said you
hadn't been alone and now all of a
sudden you were basically on your own in
this strange country i mean how much of
being detached from your family and your
tribe for that matter do you think
contributed to your
to your depression and the darkness
perhaps and the cold all of these things
yes
allah
your family is the one that
gives you your self-esteem
my mother is the one who tells me
you have value you are a good person
you are a very important person
and that's i have always to be reminded
of who i am
and in germany i tend to forget you know
who i am and i tend to forget those
people value me my mother
values me no matter what
and it's like all
every time is a wake-up call okay i'm
very important person
to my family you know to my
uh surrounding and
i always remember this eerie music at
the airport
martha otto irish emil marta emil dora
otto ulrich ulrich
otto ulrich ludwig dora siegfried ludwig
anton heinrich eda
he sees
the
the german code
to
spell my name over the phone
so to see whether i'm a wanted person
and
this is very hurtful to me
you know and my life would not
get any better and i tell you why
because
we need to mention the elephant in the
room here
why did the united states
arrest me kidnapping why were they
interesting yes well we definitely want
to get to that
yes so if you want i can go ahead and
tell you well so we've got you're in
germany you've been there a number of
years so let's sure let's progress with
the story and
that story was
i would say
three minutes
phone call that completely changed my
life
i would never be talking to you if it
hadn't been for that phone call
so in i was like
i wasn't doing very well so i'm not
saying oh i was doing very well and then
this phone call so i was like
you know i was like
struggling in my marriage
you know and
i was looking for
jobs because
you know like i told you i wasn't german
and so and it was very hard
and my papers were not
i didn't have like the green card that i
was still
waiting to get my green card
and
i just got it actually when i had this
phone call i just my life start to get
really good
and
the phone
rang
i was living in friedrich ebert strasse
i remember
and i pick it up it was my brother my
ex-brother-in-law
and he asked me he said
my father is very sick and i need your
help i said of course
he said i have some money but i cannot
transfer it
but i can send it to you to germany
because
and then you can send it to my father i
said no problem
i think it was about five thousand
dollar
if i remember correctly a lot of money
and
that's it
that was the phone call he sent me the
money and i took it physically and i
gave it to
some of the people who
come back and forth
do commerce in germany and i know
and
but there was a problem with this phone
call
this phone call was conducted from a
mobile satellite phone that belonged to
the late usame bill laden
and my brother-in-law was a close friend
to us
so so the american
you know put
one and one together and they assumed
that
i was up to no good because resemblance
back then already declared war
against
the united states against innocent
people
of the united states
i was not aware of
any of this
no i was aware of the
the problem and once i investigated when
i was taken into custody
but no no
i'm i'm forwarding really too fast
so they
so the money was sent to you and you
distribute it to some people to get it
to your friend's father that's that's
what happened correct that's it so the
money trail was very clear where the
money landed
because i was not the only person he
contacted that day he did two phone
calls i know
he contacted me and he contacted the
person who would receive the money
in in mauritania do you think he had any
sense that he was putting you in danger
to be perfectly honest
it's very hard to
to
read what was in his mind but he put me
he completely changed my life in a very
negative way right well and you did say
that his father was ill
and so
obviously he was
at least in principle motivated to help
his father
so perhaps that was obscuring his vision
i mean did he know that that
did he do you think he knew that there
was a possibility that using
telecommunication equipment that was
associated with bin laden might not be
such a good thing for you i mean maybe
he didn't i'm just curious what you
think
he took very
he he did not consult so he made this
decision for me that's for sure
and
i don't think
that he thought that the phone was even
tapped
right
but he did it now that some people who
were
sitting with the assembler day in day
out were working with the cia
very close
very close friends of sam bladden were
transmitting information
to the cia you know and he was very
blinded i guess
and i have to mention he was
investigated and he is now freeman and
they did not find any
any connection with him and any like uh
wrongdoing i see he was just associated
with
they were like friends
but he did not engage with him in any of
in any
in any attacks or anything so i i just
need to mention that okay now you also
mentioned that you were married so you
got married in germany
yes
my wife my ex-wife is a palestinian
german
and
you know
at that
and i i wasn't like doing well in my
marriage so i have to say that
and
you know i don't know whether you ever
found yourself in a relationship where
you don't want to get out of it because
you don't want to bear
the shame
of being the person who is
responsible for breaking up you know
the relationship
but
you didn't want the relationship
somehow i was in that
very bad situation right so you had a
couple of things that weren't going so
well so you were you were depressed
about your situation in germany and your
marriage wasn't going well and then this
phone call came and you you you
transmitted the money what happened
after that
that
everything went downhill
so this was like late
98 early 99.
so the the police i was not arrested i
was never interrogated i was never held
i was never invited by the police
never
so german found no ground to arrest me
or to even question but they went to our
imam that is like the priest the
equivalent of a priest in church
and
they found so they
made an appointment with the imam and
they told him this one of the people who
come to your mosque
is being investigated
and then he was laughing
and when they showed him the picture he
would he he told me later on he said
this guy wouldn't hurt a fly i know him
very well
they said that's maybe
we may even agree with you but a very
powerful country is
interested in him
and this was like almost a tip
off that i should be careful not to
travel
but i freaked out
and then i had
you heard this from the imam did he
told you this it happened and so what
did you think when he told you that
actually i wasn't surprised because my
family already called me
because when i was called this
he also called my other cousin who would
receive the money my cousin was arrested
immediately and put in prison for two
months
so my family knew that
he was being wanted he was wanted
and they told me never to receive any
phone calls from him
and not to accept his phone call and not
accept to interact with him so
i wasn't surprised actually right you
knew something was up and not something
good
yes yes
sorry who got arrested was it the person
you delivered the money to or the person
who sent the money
no the person who whom i delivered the
money to
another person was never arrested ever
and
was the person who received the money
arrested in germany
no no no no no germany is
a country ruled by law they don't arrest
you he was arrested in mauritania
because at least back then it was he
didn't respect the
proper
legal procedure
and because the the the u.s government
sent two notice one to mauritania and
one to germany germany says we cannot
arrest him without evidence mauritania
said we arrest him
that's the difference
so you received the money in germany did
you give the money to this person in
germany and then he went back to
mauritania no i sent
i sent it to him so i sent him to what
they call
loosely
so you give to
a person in germany the person person
called his family or his associates to
give the money in mauritania because
i said i see okay
they changed you know they changed money
currency okay
so use the service that did
that move money
yes absolutely absolutely that's okay so
i freaked out
and i said i need to to leave germany i
cannot live in a place where people
think i'm a bad person
and then
you know i did
so my friends
lived in montreal uh
mohsin his name is martin he's my he's
five years my
senior he finished his study at the same
university we became very good friends
and he moved to canada and he was
working and living in canada he was
canadian
since he became canadian citizen when i
arrived
and
he told me canada is a very good country
you have what you study is very
wanted and you can apply and i applied i
had this as a plan b
and i was accepted right away you know
because they need a lot of i.t people
and so on and so forth
and then i said i'm moving to canada
joining my friends
and in november
of 99
i purchased one-way ticket and i moved
to canada
as luck had it
in december 15th of december
a person by the name of ahmad rasam
tried to cross
the canadian u.s border
with explosive
and harm innocent people
so
americans said okay what's going on so
this guy had a phone call from
usama bin laden's phone and he came to
canada one month later
a guy who attended this mosque
on a one-way ticket
yeah one-way ticket
and
and they made this
this very wild theory based on
circumstances
that was very wild and very harming to
me
and this called me the mastermind of a
millennium plot
and of course they told canadian
canadians were very worried obviously
but canadian could not arrest me because
there was no evidence obviously because
i don't know the guy i never heard of
him i never met him
and
and let alone like conspiring with him
to harm innocent people in the u.s
and so did they they assumed that you
were associated with this with this
person who had been been bringing
explosives in
that i was the mastermind i see you
planned that and this was your next step
was it
correct yes correct and so canadian but
canadian did not arrest me but they were
very aggressive they put like
a listening device in the apartment
where i lived
and they
spied on my conversation i would know
that later on in guantanamo bay because
i was faced with my phone calls in
montreal
confronted i mean
and
so
american like said
this guy is very smart he does not leave
any trail this guy he speaks like german
arabic french
and his engineer and he's he's not going
to live a trip so we need
we need to lure him
to a place
where there is no law because we cannot
harass him in canada we cannot arrest
him in the u.s we cannot arrest him in
canada because in germany because
because
we don't have the evidence he needs to
provide the evidence himself
so they assumed you're an engineer that
you were multilingual that you had
purchased a one-way ticket to canada
that you were associated with bin laden
that you were tangled up with this
previous terrorist that was all part of
the and that you were and that you were
smart enough to cover your tracks
yes and i needed to be arrested
and to be wrapped up quote unquote in
order to tell them everything and people
were freaking out and
you know i i'm i'm very some
sympathetic to uh law enforcement
you know especially in democracies who
try to
protect people
and
and i i could see the logic behind
everything what i couldn't see
is
like treating someone outside the rule
of law because canada is advanced canada
is safe because of the rule of law
in the middle east countries are either
failing or failed countries because the
lack of the rule of law because
ironically those gloves
the gloves of the law
are the ones that keep
countries safe and prosperous so
canadian intelligence american
intelligence and mauritanian
intelligence
agreed to an operation that would have
me lured outside of canada and kidnapped
so
the mauritanian intelligence approached
my mother and they said muhammadu is in
a lot of trouble in canada
and you need to call him back home
and so we could like
we could like clear his name
and he could go back to canada and work
just like anyone
and who who made that claim sorry who
was the who contacted your mother
uh the mauritanian intelligence the
martini intelligence okay correct
or the lack thereof so
and
and so my mother you know she was a
bedouin and
she
her understanding that the state
you know we should abide the state
you know especially in the military like
i grew up in a military dictatorship and
we were very scared very afraid
and whatever happens she did not
understand canada is accurate by law
and
i shouldn't be afraid to be in canada so
she said whatever happens to me is
better to happen in mauritania than to
happen in canada because all countries
are the same
and so she called me said i'm sick you
need to get home
i purchased my ticket the next day and i
i i left canada on
january 20th of 2000
i arrived in dakar senegal
where my family waited on me
on 21st january 21st 2000
from the airport i was kidnapped
and interrogated in senegal
and who who picked you up who kidnapped
you
and why do you use that phrase
specifically
i don't know i guess
okay okay okay
i guess why did i use it
so
i think
it would end up in a kidnapping because
of what
of course of what i'm going to tell you
so senegalese told me we arrest you
uh
we arrest you in the name of law um
we are rescuing the name of the law
that was very okay with me very good
they took me to prison
and they interrogated me
and then they said there is no evidence
against you they told me
so you're free to go
americans said
he cannot go
they put me in a plane against my will
they're american they chose this so you
got freed from the senegalese prison
and were you were you reunited with your
family what happened what what what was
exactly the sequence of events
so america so senegalese told me
muhammad you're free to go we have
nothing against you
so americans in the embassy they ask
them not to release me because they want
me so they sent
a car
you know a suv from the embassy and the
embassy took my custody
and what did they tell you when they
picked you up
no no talking nothing
i was just put in chains and they took
me they chartered the plane
they sent me to mauritania so what did
you think was going on
i
i was thinking they want to torture me
because they want me to yes yes
because they didn't want you to go back
to canada because
they went so far i went so far i
couldn't go back because canada was like
a protection for me a protection for
quote unquote bad guy
this is a bad guy and they need to crack
he need to tell us what he did did you
know it was americans that had picked
you up when you got into the suv
yes yes yes i know because senegalese
told me americans are the one who sent
the report are the one who asked them to
arrest me
you know
you we need to understand that senegal
is a democracy
and it's ruled by law
so
and but it's not strong enough to oppose
the
the encroachment of american embassy so
they were they are not so as strong as
canadian institution
because
can in canada the us embassy cannot take
people because that would be in breach
of
grave
breach of canadian laws so
so many people would get in trouble you
know
but anyway so they put me in that plane
very small
and the the it was so small that i could
see the pilot the pilot was a female
french female pilot and she was just
like a taxi
taxi driver with small plane and she
just chartered her small plane you know
to move people who are you know from one
place to the other
and i prayed and i almost was
fantasizing that the plane crashed
and
that i survived the crash because
i i don't like pain and i read so much
about torture and i don't like torture
so
i was delivered to the mauritanian
did you have any sense at that point of
why you were in trouble
i didn't know
i didn't know but i kind of
i kind of know because canadian came to
my home
and they they told me they interrogated
me about ahmed rasna but they didn't
right right and you knew also that there
had been some trouble around the money
transfer and
did you know at that point of this
association with obama bin laden no no
nothing nothing yet okay no no no no no
mentioning given of the name of my
former brother-in-law
and
so
i
i just was i cannot describe to you
the pain
of
the prospect of being tortured
i cannot describe what were you
imagining what did you think was going
to happen
i was very serene
and
i was thinking like existential like
question
because
like
my one of my bodyguard
seems to be very religious person
because he kept like praying in the play
and i was asking myself what is the role
of religion
to
how how much can a religious person do
you know
and
where does a religious person say i'm
not doing this i'm stopping
and this was like too much like to think
about because
a guard cannot has to trust somehow the
state because he doesn't know who i am
you know as far as they're concerned
like his boss told him this is a vicious
person
he was planning to kill
random people children
women old people young people randomly
at an airport
in in the us so
and
and i was seeing my city the city of
newark shot and i could see the
the the the palette after
a storm a sandstorm
you know the colors and people very tiny
walking
and the favelas
you know where i grew up i could see
everything
and the helplessness
you know of me not being able to be
happy
because in like five minutes i would
walk out of the plane greeting my family
drinking tea
telling them
stories i knew i was going to a prison
cell
i was
almost certain i would be tortured
and
i was thinking what does feel like to be
tortured i don't know
but i read books and and i was thinking
about the brave people who
survived tortilla
and i knew jordan i was not a brave
person
because
i want to crack at the very first moment
you know
i did not want to resist
because the pain you know i love these
things jordan
the most powerful weapon
of your oppressor
is is in your mind you're right yes well
that's why i was asking you what you
were imagining you know because
i was going to be terrible
i was absolutely defeated and the pain i
felt in my stomach in my abdomen
and i i felt like
in my in my mouth very like
very
bitter taste in my mouth
and
you know
the helplessness
you know i mean sure that you you have
to appreciate where you live you have to
appreciate that you grow up in a
democracy and you take it for granted
that not
no one can take you without giving you a
reason why they take it to the police
and you have a big mouth you can say no
i need a lawyer i don't need to talk to
you
and
you can like
start and develop your narrative with
your lawyer everything you know to save
yourself
none of that so in in a
a country that is not ruled by law
you have none of these rights you know
so they took me in
renault 12
from airport very old
and you know mauritania will we are like
bedouin and they would they want to put
a mask over my face though i couldn't
see they didn't have a mask prepared
and then one of them gave me his turban
that he used on his head he said you
need to wrap this turban around your
hand
very tightly
and i could smell his sweat
you know
and
so they took me
to a secret prison
and
they start interrogating
so and like my paths start to come out
so in my past
in 91 between 1992 i spent a couple of
months
on two different occasions in
afghanistan
they came to our mask
and they wanted like to
gather like money and so it was a very
big
like thing in germany and this was a
campaign that was
that was supported by germany supported
by the u.s by my government by canada by
the u.s to help the mujahideen the
so-called mujahideen and i was very
young i said oh i need to be part of
this and i went there
and i didn't like it and then i left but
this was nonetheless something i told
them i'm sorry i went there and so
and
and so after
one month of interrogation mauritanian
they did not torture him they did not
torture him
so
and
they
and did did anything else come to light
during that interrogation that cast you
in a bad
in a bad light that that was hard on
your reputation
no nothing nothing because it turns out
mauritanian knew that i went to
afghanistan because
they it's in my passport because i want
there is a stamp in my passport so they
knew that and what only came to light
was that
that
i don't know they told me like
americans wouldn't provide them any
evidence and
they were stuck because because
mauritanian told americans to take me
but americans refused
and
mauritania like were
actually
breaking the law by offering me because
you cannot
turn off a military citizen once they
hit the military ground so you have to
try them if they did any crimes no
matter what so why
why do you think you weren't tortured
was it was it a standard practice there
and or not and and if so why did you
escape torture
okay
you see like
intelligence like
in
authoritarian regime they don't just
jump on you and torture you they have to
have good reason so we have to be very
objective when we describe things
so they told me if i don't cooperate
with them they will torture me
if there is evidence they have to know
i'm hiding something but americans
wouldn't provide them any evidence that
i'm hiding anything that i didn't tell
them
and i adamently told them that i had no
clue about millennium blood i don't know
ahmad rasam i never met him and american
wouldn't give them any evidence to the
contrary
so they so they were somewhat inclined
to believe you
they did believe me
they did believe me and they told
american either you give us the evidence
or we're going to release him
and then american asked them a favor
they said okay take away his passport
and don't let him go back to canada
mauritanian intelligence as usual
ever breaking the law they took my
passport and they did not allow
and canadians
also
ask them not to allow me to travel back
to canada because canadians found them
in a very hot spot
because canada is the
very close to the us
and
they just don't want any trouble with
the big brother and which is
understandable
and
i said to myself okay they took my
passport
i
went there i went
to i applied for job and i found a very
good job as a programmer
and
administrator
and i started like writing code
and until 9 11 happened i was arrested
kidnapped
and that's it
and tortured
all right so you're you're you're in
mauritania they let you out of
you you've been imprisoned there but
you have a story and and the
mauritanians accept the story what
happens after that
so they told me i cannot travel because
the united states did not want to travel
and i said okay i just find a job in
mauritania you know my dream my dreams
of studying for my phd in canada were
dashed i said
it's okay you know i i need to work
anyway and then i found a job in
mulitania and
i start start feeding my family for like
over a year until 9 11 happens
and
everything changed
so you're in mauritania 9 11 happens but
you're working and you're taking care of
your family in mauritania
and and so 9 11 happens and what happens
to you what's the consequence of that on
on 29th of
september that is about a little bit
over two weeks
after 9 11 i received a phone call
again
from the police retaining police
and they said we need to talk to you
i said okay
the guy said where are you i said where
are you
i'm coming to you
and they said okay i'm at this in that
place
and then i drove my car
and met him
and he was very frank he told me
american told us to arrest
i said why don't you tell them
that i didn't do anything he said
they're very angry because of 9 11 and
just bear with me
they just will
ask you some questions they will let you
go and then they came
and
they brought the german translator
and then
they interrogated me i don't know who
interrogated me so
a guy maybe cia maybe fbi maybe i don't
know
and where did that take place
in mauritanian prison
and okay
and
they left
and then
again murutana released me and then
after
one month
they took me again
and then they told me that american
wants me in jordan
and i lost it i lost it i said
this is too much
because
i guess american figured out this is his
home this is his tribe
and this is a corrupt regime maybe
they're protecting we need to take him
outside of his comfort zone where he has
no tribes and we torture him
and then he will
he will like tell us everything
and that's exactly what happened so they
took me
so they took me to the airport
the mo now was that mauritanians or
americans that took you to the airport
okay so you're taken to the airport
yes and they put me in a plane with
five
people
two
uh sex people
two uh pilots
because they two pilots
and two uh interrogators
and two uh
people with masks i couldn't they didn't
talk they just with masks
like a kind of commandos
special team
and
so when they so what were you thinking
in on this plane
what
what should i
say so much pain
i just died a thousand times
you know i know i was going to torture i
know 100 i was going to do
and the the the ride was about 12 hours
and one of the station one of the
airplane one of the airport was in
cyprus
cyprus is part of the european union and
the signatory of uh convention against
torso just like mauritania
and
i was hoping
that they would
that they would board the plane
and inspect the people
passports and everything because
for an african guy to get a visa to
europe it's almost like next to
impossible but now
i'm going through europe without even a
passport
and i want to be arrested as a criminal
and put in prison
you know
and this never happened because
everybody was on in it and i say jordan
this is one of the biggest
of the biggest betrayal of u.s citizens
united states stood with europe against
the national socialism
and
europe after 9 11 enabled the united
states
to gravely violate human rights instead
of standing up to the government said no
american people deserve better
and america is better than doing this
america is ruled by the law america
should lead the world in human rights it
should not violate human rights because
this
would open
a can of warmth and would give like a
carte blanche to all those horrific
regimes
to do whatever they wanted
and i landed in jordan
and then i was put in this secret prison
and most of the time i didn't know day
from nights
you know i was beaten only two times
during eight months
and
but the thing that hurt me so much when
they took me to listen to torture
sessions
you know they blindfolded me
they put me in a room and they start
torturing this person
you know for me to break
and
i couldn't do you think that
was that taped do you think or was it
something that was happening right there
do you think
jordan
i didn't know i mean yes very smart
smart question but i mean it doesn't
matter really from your perspective when
you're there because but i'm you know
i'm
curious i suppose about the methods
yes yes i mean
it's it's horrific the problem that
the problem with that
i couldn't get the the
the cries
of my head yeah so they put me back in
my cell i couldn't sleep
i couldn't sleep for this and then i
would like plug my ears
and then i hear even louder when i pluck
my eyes
you know
the more i plug my ears the more i hear
it because
because it's in the brain
and the brain does not need
your eyes or your ears to see or hear
you know because the brain how often
were you exposed to that sort of thing
i remember like
uh
maybe a dozen
but i i was only moved twice so i have a
question for you if you had to be beaten
or you had to listen to people being
tortured i know this is a terrible
question but it speaks to
the intensity of listening to people
being tortured which of those was more
torturous
listening absolutely no question asked
why
yes
because
when they start beating me
okay
a lot of anxiety
and a lot of inside pain goes away
because my body is weak
and the problem is to have like strong
body and destroyed soul
because somehow the soul and body has to
be balanced out so
if you like if you threat
threaten me
and then you put me in a situation
especially you have power over me put me
in a situation that is so painful and i
i'm eating myself from inside
but when you
beat me
and then you cause me pain
and that pain
this is horrible to say but it's good
for me
to uh
because it weakens my
the sharpness of my mind to
to process
the perceived pain that i may be
receiving
it's like when you have depression and
when you walk or when you work out
workouts just torturing yourself
and then it goes dissipate somehow
so how long were you in prison in jordan
very good question
so
i tried to keep like
to keep a calendar in my head
so i say one
two
three
i wasn't bad
so when when they told me you are going
out
i
they gave me a paper to sign
i was expecting
july 31st 2002
i saw the paper july 20 or 21st i don't
remember
i was completely off you know because
nights and days for somehow
somehow mixed with each other
i don't know why well you said you
weren't sleeping well and that's not
surprising and so that could easily i
mean and you're and i presume how much
time did you spend outside
uh
maybe 20 minutes
or 25 minutes outside
it per day or in total
no in total
oh so never really
yes
and what did you one time outside and i
was so scared
because
you you know you are so vulnerable when
you are exposed to torsion
because
you feel like i want my torture i want
to be close to my tongue i want my
torture to be to be satisfied
you know i wanted to put me in this cell
because that's what satisfies them
you know i don't want to be in a big
space you know
and it's very weird to explain
because i saw
this torture has a god-like
power you know they give you food
they talk to you they said if you are a
good guy i'm going to treat you well if
you are a bad guy i'm going to punish
you this is immediate
immediate power
you know
and
yes so
so i want to tell you this epiphany a
little bit because
because
uh it's very important
to understand like this kind of
forgiveness
that i really have uh in my heart
so they came to me i was very weak after
eight months of battery
eight months of
mind destruction mind and body i was
very weak i was about
less than 100 pounds and i'm
171 or 172
centimeters and less than 100 pound is
really very skinny
so
i
so they
they gave me these guys throw
a bag a garbage bag in my cell said
you're going home
then i took the bag i had very small
belonging like this big like
like
underwear and i think i had a t-shirt
that's it
and then
he told me
to turn around
ironically that's a sign of respect to
give your back
side to the guard
because he wants to control you and put
your hands back behind your back and
shackle them
and then he led me always blindfolded
i was never let to see anything except
when they pushed me inside the cell
and then they they they
they remove the
and then i sat in a chair like this
facing a guy middle-aged guy
he looks he spoke almost like a
religious figure
and
it was like everybody around him was
like out of focus because like a movie
you know people who cannot see them very
well
my eyes were glued on him
and he was telling me okay this is your
belonging
okay and i was supposed to say that he
was right i got everything back i think
i had eighty dollar
something like that or a hundred dollar
i don't know and then had my canadian
driver license
german driver license
passport
and they said this everything
of course i said yes
what did you expect me to say and so
this summary judgment
of that would show that the prison staff
was good
was done very quickly
and what i wanted at that moment i want
to pee
but i couldn't tell him i want to pee
because i want to go home
and then they put me in this house
like
blindfold
earmuffed everything then they drove me
to the airport
i could hear the roars of the engines
because i was on the runway
and all of a sudden
someone start to
like cut open my clothes
with very sharp scissors
and then they stripped me completely
naked and they put a diaper on that
person
i figured i'm not going home
and i'm not going
to another prison in jordan i'm going to
the u.s
and this was
like confirmed
when this guy briefly
uh
removed
the blindfold and open my eyes and i
could see his blonde
blond hair on his
on his arm
he did not say anything and he had like
very black
very black bag
on his face mask on his face well could
only see the eyes
and
blue eyes i presume
i don't know this fake memory but
i figured he is not a jordanian
and
i just imagined that this was the end of
my life
did you think at any time then that you
like had your hopes being raised that
you were maybe going home
no after this i knew i was not before i
meant on the way before before you hit
the airport did you think that maybe you
were going to be free
i was crying all the time
and i was saying this is the first time
in my life i would enjoy a bathroom
in an airplane i hate bathrooms in
airplanes
and
this is so good and i would meet my
family
and i would this is so like
imagination and then i was like but i
was kind of
like destroyed mentally because i was
thinking
uh how could i live because i was in
prison with good relationship with god
and i was like pure in my soul and then
now i'm going back to to life and you
know in life you have to fight with
people
you know
and then to do you have to do the wrongs
because like occupational hazard of
living your life
and
and then it hit me
after that i mean after they start to
put me in new clothes and diapers that i
would have a very long ride and it's
going to the us and if i figured
i would die
forgotten in a very violent
prison american prison what do you think
the purpose of the diapers was
the purpose of the diapers because
very long flights
and you cannot they with security they
will not take you to any place you have
to pee
in your diet i see i see okay
so this is very important because at
least to my mind
because
this moment changed my life forever
my life
uh before this
cia team that took me from jordan
and after the cia took me from jordan
are two different episodes that have
very little to do with each other and i
tell you why
so
when i came to the
to the conclusion that i will die this
is it this is my life
done i start to reflect on my past
and then i start to regret
and there is only one thing i regretted
in my life
one single thing i regret
i regretted not to be nice enough
to people
i regretted when i told my mom i didn't
like this food this food is not as i
expected
i regretted when i get some time when i
got sometimes angry and i express my
anger in a very
then in a less than nice way
i did not regret not having money i did
not regret not having this beautiful
woman i always dreamed about
i did not regret not being in a position
of power in my life all the things
that
demand so much effort and work
had no value to me
and the things that are so easy to do in
life
are the ones that matter to me
being
nice
and i took it upon myself
if allah
god
allows me to live again
i promise to be a nice person to
everyone i need no matter what
you know and that's that's what the
change in mind why do you why do you
think that
transformation occurred then
what
what's your understanding of of why that
occurred
this is like the first time
that
i really thought that i would never see
life again that i will die in an
american prison
that's then
i had so to
to face my past because
that's you know it's just facing death
and
it's strange the way that facing death
would make you reevaluate your life like
that
no because in some sense you'd think
it's a bit late isn't it i mean if you
think you're going to die but then that
all those thoughts come to mind that you
could have been a better person and
yes it's
i know i know but
it's like your soul is being weighed you
know in in light of your impending death
and you're evaluating your whole life
yes absolutely and i mean
i mean this is like
you know in a very weird way i think i'm
lucky because
i had the unique you know experience
maybe not unique but
very few people at this experience you
had it
that they faced that and they said what
should i change in my life what should i
change in my life and i knew what i need
to change
you know i i i didn't i know i don't
need
a lot of money of course i love to have
money of course
but i wouldn't like break my back or
break my head to make money absolutely
not
but i make so much effort painful effort
to be a nice person and it's not easy to
be a nice person and what do you mean by
by being a nice person what does that
entail as far as you're concerned
absolutely
so when i'm
upset with you
or with my family
i have to control what i say
i have to control what i do
because i always want to leave a good
taste
no matter what
also when some someone ask me for help
i have to provide them help without
hurting myself the only way
i deny help if this help very help is
going to hurt me
and
that's not a problem to me to deny to
not accept to her
and that's it just being nice to people
making a difference smiling you know to
people you know making them feel good
this is very important
you said that when you were in germany
uh that you had fits bouts of depression
that were long lasting what about now
it's
very i'm
very
depressed
like i have this
this
ptsd
scene like uh episodes
right that will send me to the hospital
for many days and i almost died one of
the
reason for
this very bad episode was taking clone
up in what they call at least in the u.s
clone opinion
and
this was started in prison because i was
really i was
very very much a vegetable when it comes
then they prescribed me chronic pain
and then they cut it called turkey yes
one day some experience with that yes
it's terrible
it's oh my god you cannot explain to
someone
it was it was absolutely unbearable oh
my god oh my god when i think about how
long did that last
i don't know because i i i could i
didn't have feeling for time
but
the pain i keep hitting my head against
the the wall
and
i was crying like a child
i was crying like a child and this was
definitely
a male a practice you know in in in
prison you know because
because i read later on that it could
kill you
you know it makes you wish you were dead
that's for sure
oh my god it's it's horrific you know
like
like depression
depression
you cannot describe depression to
someone who who didn't go through it
because they always i always told people
are you just a crying baby
what hurt so do you have like injury
physical body injury no so why are you
like acting up very much
you know why are you tripping
you know but
this is when i have this episode
i cannot eat
i cannot drink
i cannot sleep
i'm so scared
i have always to have someone beside me
you know watching over me
you know and
i'm much better now i'm much better now
but i acknowledge
that i'm very vulnerable
i'm
very weak there are heavy stuff that i
need to deal with
you know
with professional help and so on and so
forth so i'm not
going to put a brave face
and try to sell you something that is
not there
yep
all right so let's go back to the plane
so you're on the plane to the united
states
and you think
yes i thought it was to the united
states
and then
i almost
died because
i couldn't pee in the
in the diaper i kept squeezing
but my head refused to pee
you know and
after
why what i thought five hours the plane
started to lose
altitude
i was telling no this is not the u.s yes
it's not five hours
and then
it landed
and then they took me
out because i felt the wind
and then they put me in a chopper
because very loud i could hear through
the ear
and then they put me in a truck and then
i start hearing language i never heard
before
it's not english it's not german it's
not arabic
it turns out it's some tribal afghani
language that i never heard
and
so i landed turns out
in bagram
air base
and then they took me
to this prison
and i spent
that's they started torture in that
prison
and
so but it's not like very heavy they
just like keep me
like
on my knees
for very long hours
you know i couldn't see and then
very much and then they put like strobe
light
over my head for hours
and
they
first night they came to took me
and no peeing first so when they put me
they stripped me
naked and they put me in
in some clothes and i said they set me
and i
peed pee pee like there is no tomorrow
then i felt so good i didn't care what
they did to me
because now i peed because
because now i felt i'm a free person i'm
surviving you know
and
so they took me they asked me what
languages they
brought arabic translated they asked me
what language i spoke
then i said german among others
they said german you're a liar
because
who speaks german in this one no one
and then
they brought a special agent ci agent
who spoke german
write them and then he spoke to me in
german
and he looked at him and said these guys
speak german better than i
and then he looked at me he said
var height mach fry
will set you free
because
because i
what came in my mind is this sign
yes
and and it came to me that those people
are by did not set them free
work did not settle no i know
i was in big
big trouble
and then he interrogated me he was not
bad
you know he was like
he was like explain to me a lot of
american culture and so and he told me
very much that i was screwed
because
in america
it's uh he told me
uh accusation is enough
in this
in this situation
yes that's enough that's enough you will
not be free
for a very long time and you maybe he
said you may be guilty or not i don't
know i don't have the information but i
can assure you that you would be treated
as a guilty person
and he was very frank with me and
he well the assumption would have to be
the part of the on the part of the
people that have now arrested you and
that were bringing you back to the
united states they're all going to
assume that you're guilty
obviously
correct absolutely absolutely and
this is the greatness of democracy of
the rule of law that the state violence
is kept in check is the state violent
violence anywhere in the world
it doesn't matter your culture it
doesn't matter whether you're christian
you're jewish
you're muslim
your agnostic your buddhist
human beings always commit
atrocities against other human beings
and the state has so much
tools of oppression that the state
cannot be must not be
just left without checks
i mean it's okay to say uh jordan is a
bad person that's okay to say especially
by the state but the state cannot harm
you or put you in prison
if they don't have
evidence that is
that can be checked
by a third independent party that is
that does not subscribe to the
bureaucracy
of the state
and you know this is like uh this is
like everywhere and
this obsession
you know
you know 9 11 was very horrific act you
know
and let's say that full stop
so
the united states in the united states
there was a very big debate you know
whether democracy and the rule of law
can
protect
the united states of america and a lot
of people in the cia in fbi
and
what's not
believed
that the rule of law is not enough they
have to go outside the rule of law in
order to protect the united states and
they have this obsession with
dictatorial regimes
uh from the middle east i know this
because they told me
that you know they don't need gloves
they go down and dirty and so and and i
was like oh my god i grew up in a
military destination and people are not
safe in a military dictatorship
well democracy might not be
make people safe but there isn't an
alternative that makes them more safe
so absolutely
absolutely and democracy is
millions times safer
than dictatorships
you know because in a dictatorship there
is no
way around corruption there is no way
around corruption you know any
dictatorships you know and the
corruption would hit also the security
apparatus
you know and i know this because i could
see the contrast where i grew up
during military rule and germany germany
you can walk anytime you want
no one is going to hurt you no one is
and in germany
you know
no one can arrest you without due
process no
and this whole like obsession that
you know we need to treat people outside
the rule of law that's how we protect
i say
this is wrong and this is just an
opinion this is not a scientific i don't
have a scientific but i would say is
wrong and the empirical evidence is in
the
in the uh what we see
western democracies are much safer than
any other country in the middle east
so back to the helicopter
i was taken out of the
aircraft and put in a chopper
and
i have to mention
that the cia did not torture me during
the
trip from jordan no this guy was very
gentle he didn't hurt me
and that that wouldn't be the role in
the future because in guantanamo bay
and in
in bagram every move
the guards who moved me
they roughed me up and they they used
you know the move from one place to the
next
to uh
inflict pain on me like pinching me
or dragging me you know
or run away
and they know i cannot run because i
have shackles on my
feet
but this all
happened i think
uh on the instructions of my
interrogators so anyway so they took me
and
i peed for the first time on my knees
and that felt really really good i
didn't care about anything else and i
was stripped naked again
and then they took a hair
you know from
my hair
you know
and
they interrogated me
the first interrogation didn't seem
they didn't seem to be very well
informed about who i was
they just had the script
it was like where is usama bin laden
where
is former president of the taliban
and
they didn't know that
i was in a prison i wasn't out there i
wasn't picked up from a battlefield so i
had no clue and where did that
interrogation take place
right when i was taken out of the
chopper
and
so and this so interrogation was done
they took me put me in an isolation cell
and this woman came to me
she said
if you want to to go to the bathroom i
remember this you can ask this person
because there was no bathroom in my cell
and
you know like
i didn't speak english and
bathroom sounds like bad it seemed like
just
literal translation but in german means
something else it means a place where
you take a bath
and i was thinking oh my god those
people are so nice i really want to take
a bath
i said i wanted to go to the bathroom
and they took me to
to a barrel
full of human feces
and
just
you know put in a place and then they
said this is the bathroom
because they didn't have like
they didn't have like
bathrooms like they have just like
barrels and then detainees would do in
their barrels
and it's very tricky because it's
hanging it's light
it's like very high high up
and
and then that was my first english you
know real english word so that bathroom
is not a place to take a bath
and
i was taken to guantanamo bay
it was
very torturous
i mean they
you know
again so we were put
in the same shackle we were about 34 i
think detainees
and there was a shackle that you know
connected all of us
and
they start processing us
blindfold
all kind of shackles
and put us in the plane
and i couldn't breathe because i have
claustrophobia
i almost died you know
and
this guy came to me and he told me
forget about it
i
never forget this
and it was like okay either i survive or
i die so i'm not going to get
any relief
because i wanted him to remove the
the mask on my face because i couldn't
breathe because of the mask
you know just like this uh
this uh
this
corona mask
you know but i couldn't breathe with it
you know i think mostly because
of my
claustrophobia and
we arrived in guantanamo bay after i
think more than 30 hours
and
it was like oh my god i was so happy
that i arrived somewhere because so much
pain you know everywhere
and
they put me
like they pushed me
you know in
what seemed like open space
and then i felt the sun
and then you know i was like you know
this is
you know this is much better
in my mind
now i'm under the full authority of the
united states no more you were 30 hours
in transport before then you thought you
thought it was about that
i think it was more
yes what what kind of transport was it
were you you said you were on a plane
yes and the plane changed places
i think
changed place and stopped somewhere you
know
i stopped somewhere
once or twice
right so it was a direct flight
no no no it wasn't
and so i arrived so i we started off
on in the morning of
4th of august 2002 and we arrived
the next day
4th of august 5th of august
and they processed us and i remember
this gentleman came coming to me and he
he spoke in russian too
and i didn't speak any russian
and then
you know we were all naked because they
stripped us in the room
and
looks like you cannot get those images
out of your head you know
you are naked watching naked people
around you you know
and this guy looked at me i was smiling
all the time
you know and
this guy looked at me and said where did
they capture
i remember this question
and i didn't understand it he i kept
said what he kept said where did he
capture him and then he was very
frustrated with me
and then he said never mind something
like never mind
and
and then
ah then i understand i said home
something like that
and
because i was captured
home
and the last thing i saw
when the police came to me was
the
image of my mother as we drove
away
with the police i saw her in the
rearview mirror because i was driving my
car and a policeman sat beside me
and she was getting smaller smaller
smaller and until i
right and then she disappeared
at that point i did not think that i
would never see my mother again but i
never saw my mother
i was never allowed to attend her
funeral i was never allowed to say
goodbye to my mom
and
so we arrived
my first interrogation
they put me in a room
and you know i was like being kind of
demanding because i thought oh this is a
cell
and
i said but this cell is small but it was
really big big room
you know human beings are very you know
they always like
compare
and
i thought this is like very small
then i tried to
stand up and discover my surroundings
there was no one
and then i was dragged really forcefully
down and then i saw there is a bolt
holding me to the ground i was not aware
of
and
then i realized i'm not free in this
room i cannot move around
these
two gentlemen
three gentlemen came in the room
one is bill
he said his name is bill
and he's from the fbi he was about my
age
you know
30 about
early 3rd 31
and
another person by the name of
paul his name is paul i know his name
and then announcement you can remember
these are these details
and then a translated from morocco
because i didn't speak english
and then they came
to my room
and then
they started asking me question
and the and paul
had
an empty water bottle and he kept
spitting in it
and i was saying what does he spit
and then it was like very disgusting and
black
and then later on i learned this is
normal in the u.s you know i was like
looking at the uss you know very
sophisticated people and they have like
you know
like so he was chewing tobacco
yes he was shooting tobacco they were
spitting in front of everybody
and
everybody could see the disgusting like
spit
very thick very black
and i know i'm not sophisticated i know
my people are not sophisticated i know
that because
that's where i grew up but
my image of americans because of the
movies
very sophisticated you know very like
clean very organized
that was my first glimpse i know they're
just like other human beings
and
i was just
waiting on the other fbi guy to pick his
nose because that's the next level you
know spitting in a battle
you need to pick your nose to complete
the picture
and
they didn't do anything they asked me
whether i was
mistreated in jordan
i said
i don't want to answer that question and
that was for
a couple of reasons
i didn't want
to i didn't want to
tell them that it's possible to torture
me i didn't want them to know it's
normal
and the second thing
i didn't want them
i didn't want them to trick me
into uh giving them details you know i
just want to keep it very
very brief with them so no information
about that or they said it's not
necessary
but they told me in the united states we
don't torture people and i was very
happy
because that's what i thought too
because i watched
married with children a comedy which was
very funny
and
i watched law and order
back home so
this is america funny
and
the rule of law
so they kept this interrogation like
almost on a daily basis
but i wasn't confessing to any
any amazing stuff they were not
discovering anything and that was very
frustrating to them
so they the the commander
of the base
and
other people demanded that i need to
i need to be
put in a program to encourage me to
cooperate with them
i was blissfully unaware but in
washington they were devising
a program of torture so-called
enhanced interrogation technique that
was devised just for me
you know
and
i don't know everything it's in there
but i think it's a document that is
accessible
you know
but
what i received was
sexual assault i mean full physical
contacts not like
it's not like dirty talking or
that because that happened too but i'm i
mean direct you know
like uh sexual assault rape
and that was really bad and then the
first 70 days
when they took me
i remember the first day
so the fbi came to me on
22nd
of may 2002
and the fbi guy
no 2003 sorry
my bad and the fbi guy his name was
his name was
was
rob seidler robert zeidler
he gave me a book
called america and its people
it's about the history of america you
know
you know it's
you know
and i love history and
how had you learned to speak english by
that point
yes a little bit with very heavy accent
but i understood
almost everything i read because of my
french vocabulary
and
and uh
and i i like to read a lot when
especially in prison when you have
whenever they give you something i keep
reading it so i read these americans
people many times like it's very
academic
and
so
and he told me
this is the last day his boss told him
that
i was not giving him the information and
he told me that my life was
going to change
and that he
he wants me to cooperate with the next
team
and
so
later on i think one month so they try
to another team try to intimidate me
everything
like military and
other undefined agencies
but
i told them no i'm not talking to you
anyway so
you can do whatever you want kind of was
very defiant kind of
very stupid from
and
well what what would have been your
alternative
what what else could have you done do
you think
was it was there anything else other
than
i mean if if you had nothing to confess
it's not that straightforward to
cooperate
obviously
yes it's impossible them you do it then
you don't
because
look i thought about this a lot
if you confess
without torture
that's very heavy burden
i had to wait on torture
because
that's the only way
you you could
and this is hindsight you could explain
i didn't do this this is torture you
know
and
so
i was very scared but i kept saying you
need to tell me what i did and then i
can cooperate with you as long as you
don't tell me i'm not going to cooperate
and i was very like
measured
and logical
and defiant
and even smart
kind of
smart with them like
i can tell you for instance they tell me
ask me like fbi asked me question
even before the the program okay they
asked me the same question next day and
i say you asked me yesterday and i
answered
then they would say but we want to make
sure are not lying
and i would say
i remember all the lies i said since i
left home
so and i was comfortable enough
to uh
let out my frustration with them
you know
this
is going to change dramatically
so
they came to me the guards
and then they came in front of my cell
on mike black
and they said reservation
that's the code word
that you are going to be taking away
and
i said where because usually they tell
you interrogation or medical or
something so why they taking
they told me it's none of your business
and i knew i was in trouble
and then so they had this
these rubber rubber gloves
and then when they start put me in
shackle i read on the rubber glove india
black
and then i i told detainees my
co-detainees i'm going to be taken to
india india black is torture black so
we know that because
there was only the black was
designed for 30 detainees
but there was only one detainee they
take only one or two detainees for
torture so
they
and
so when they took me there i found one
detainee and soon that the thing was
taken away so i was
by myself
the
the first 70 the first 70 days in that
blood
no sleep
so and you would ask how how how could
you sleep sleep is you just sleep you
know
so the the way they did it interrogation
so they have like three shifts
so one interrogator then the next
interrogate and then the next
interrogation just like
you know
like uh conveyor belt in a car
uh industry plan
and
how did they keep you awake i mean after
a couple of days you must have been like
falling asleep at every second
correct correct so
they
put me back in myself
and then
they they let me lie down and then the
guard kept banging every like one hour
or so they come and bang
at my
door and it's so cold you cannot sleep
because
freezing cold
in the cell and i didn't have proper
claws so it was
to be honest the recollection is really
hazy because i was not in the state of
mind
to remember i may have very false a lot
of false memories but i can only tell
you with the best of my guests
what went on
and
later on they made very efficient
methods that most efficient i know this
is bad because other people would like
to torture people they would know this
but i can tell you very efficient
every hour they wake me up and they make
me drink water every hour
wake you up make you drink water you can
never sleep when someone does this to
because you will always go to the
bathroom
continuously
you will like be half asleep go to the
bathroom half a sleep going to the
bathroom have a sleep
over and over and over
the only method they didn't do to me
and the guard told me about it because i
confessed
and falsely confessed was shower
they he told me and the other thing they
put him under the shower and they turn
on the shower 24 7.
i wasn't looking forward to that
so
i didn't know because
i kept negotiating
my
torch
i kept telling them i'm dying you know
and it i actually it was true because
guru rahman died another detail this is
on record gul rahman you can lock it up
he died in the cold room he couldn't
take it
because hypothermia set in
and they found him dead in his cell
and so the room was artificially cooled
yes yes
but
i have to say this they they didn't like
bring
to my mind they didn't bring like
special equipment to cool it down they
just like
completely cracked up the
ac
to its fullest
you know
because the ac was not designed to kill
people
but i do believe that where you grow up
i'm sure a canadian will not die under
nac but a mauritanian like me growing up
in the desert
it's very harmful to them because my
body is not used to
this type of temperature and i kept
telling them you are killing i mean
and i remember this doctor because when
i say like
these things i'm saying with love
because i know american people are good
people just like
any like canadian like within by a large
are good people
and i remember this doctor i think he's
a commander or in the navy
he was a doctor
and
part of the program torture program i'm
not allowed to take medication
okay
for pain relief because that would
defeat the purpose of the torch
and but i was really very sick because
of my
psychic nerve and they took me to this
doctor commander
he has a leaf
i think they call it a command
and
he looked at them he said remove the
shackles
and then they removed he said do not
give me the thinness with shackle on my
table something like it was very upset
and then i saw my window i said oh this
is a good guy i need to complain
you know i was like drowning and i was
just seeing anything and tried saying
i said i'm really doing i'm having so
much pain i really needed to talk to
them to stop this he told me i cannot
he told me that
the the he cannot interfere with
interrogation
you know but he would write a report
that i'm really very sick
and he did write the report and the
reason why i know he did because years
later on my interrogators found the
report in their discovery discovery
means
when your lawyer asked for
secret documents you know related to
your case
and
but i was just like
doing nothing they just i let them do
their things i'm not talking to them
nothing
just like a stone every day
and sometimes i say a little when they
like
be nice to me but say something that has
nothing to do with anything
and
one day
it was i think august 23rd when i
remember correctly of 2003
august 23rd
a man
a police lieutenant by the name of
richard zully
later on i learned he's from chicago
and he's very infamous because
he was involved in torturing some people
back in chicago in the u.s mainland
he came to me
and i sat in front of him he was very
stern very serious and he handed me a
letter
from dod and he asked me to read it
in that letter
it says that
due to the lack something like duties
the lack of mind of my
cooperation the us government
has
had no choice
but to arrest my mother and put her in
only men prison
and that
they know that i was involved in
millennium plot and in
the atrocious acts of 9 11 etc etc
i didn't know how to answer but i i
because i was very scared i told him
this is unfair i didn't know what to say
and he told me
we are not looking for justice
we are
trying to stop people from
driving planes into the buildings
something like that i'm sure his english
is much better than mine
and i was like okay go ahead and look
for those people
you know so when he left i knew i had
nothing more to lose and i was
ready to confess to everything and
anything
and uh
but i didn't know how i didn't know how
to start it
you know
and but he helped me so
i uh
i don't know a couple of days
later on or one day i don't remember i
was in in the interrogation room with
sub sergeant mary you know mary you know
you know she she has her human side even
though she
actively
participating torsion
notably notably in
sexual assault
you know she was kind of
you know
at least ambivalent about what she was
doing
and these like
three masked men
flat came to the room
and then one of them was holding german
shepherd
and the other star just putting me down
beating me everywhere like me like
viciously beating
and then she stood up and she was crying
she was like why you do this why you do
this like it was like total chaos
they took me out of the room
never stopped beating me until i stopped
breathing because i couldn't breathe
anymore because my ribs broke
and it was like the the
the pressure on my
on my lungs and the pain of
breathing through
your broken ribs is just so so painful
and i was like
all the time and they were like making
fun of this noise
i couldn't see anything
you know then they took me they start
putting this water
you know forcing this saltwater
my nose my mouth and then they give me
to another team i don't know three hours
and then another team
and
richie julie stood i could hear him
in the pose
before they gave him to the next team he
was like
kind of we appreciate the cooperation of
all countries to take down the
terrorists something like that you know
and
this
guy with egyptian accent
his english was very poor
and
another guy from syria i only spoke
arabic
i would say syrian accent to be precise
because there was no way for me to know
he is no no jordanian accent
so
and so they took me and those people
utilize a different technique so what
they did they strapped me on a chair
very you know very like strong chair
and then they put something over my body
like overall i believe
and then they start beating me beating
me
until i couldn't take any money they
fill everything with eyes
everything
then when this eyes start to melt they
come back and beat
and they were saying that
i will confess and so and they
are going to take me to egypt and to
jordan in my mind i was thinking but
i've been to jordan and no miracles
happen so why they take me again to
for them
and one thing in my mind since richard
zulu meeting i want to confess i want to
say everything but
i didn't know how to do it
honestly that was only my problem
they
so they took me around 5 30 p.m
and
about 1 30 in the morning next day
because i saw the watch of the
medic
as he
start to treat me
so he came they put me in a cell
and
the medic
you know was masked and they say when
you i can do this and that i'm going to
break your teeth so he was part of the
torture team
you know so much for do no harm
and
so he treated me actually so he put like
some band
band-aid around my
around my
ribs
a lot of it and he gave me a lot of
medication i don't know what it was
and then
this was
august 24th or 25th i don't remember
but this is
how long had you been there by then
no this is a new prison so
this is a new prison the night i came
this is a new prison
so i stayed there almost
until one year before my release or two
years before my release so i never
so
what i remember vividly are two things
between so this is august
and the second thing i remember
october 10th
october 10th because i saw a watch
you know again the interrogator was
sitting and looked briefly at his watch
and then i saw the day
but
just before
that
you know i was
i cannot describe to you how much pain i
was in because
i cannot
there are no words
i'm alone
i don't know where
i don't know days and or nights
i
they start this diet manipulation they
make me
they withhold foods for i don't know how
many days until i almost die and they
give me a lot of like
me america to eat very bad food at least
to me
but i cannot eat it because when i'm
depressed i cannot eat
and they give too many things they give
me one minute but they don't respect the
minute i think they give 20 seconds and
they take everything back
and but i'm happy because i don't want
to see them i don't want i just want
like to pass
and die
without pain
you know something like that
and
so
so i i start in myself to think like
quran when they are let there like to
sing to
to
to uh
just to feel good like praying so and
they came to me with force
he said if i pray again they will beat
me up
and then they force feed me when ramadan
came they come during their first feed
me i didn't know it was
i know somehow
but
and
actually i know
some somewhere during day i know
somewhere during the why
when i go to the bathroom i look inside
the bathroom
and i could see the light of the day
through the
plumbing
so and that's the time
when they force feed me very little just
to make sure i'm not respecting ramadan
so that's only i'm just trying to put
you in the picture
that to understand how
how destroyed my spirit was
then i did this prayer and i asked allah
for guidance i e god because i didn't
know what to do
and in my mind
nothing i would tell them would stop
this
i called one of the guards
i don't know their names their masks too
and i said i need to see
captain collins
richard zuli called himself captain
collins that's what he called himself
and
he came to me
and i told him
i want to confess
he said okay
i will send you the people
and he sent me
first sergeant child
and first necessarily start
asking
and then i was just like
no stop ask me do you know
like
jordan peterson yes he's a terrorist i
know him i saw him he was preparing you
know
everybody i know is a bad guy
and
so
and then
you know because interrogation is a
technique they don't ask you the hard
question in the beginning they always
start softly where did you study
what school did you go to you know to
prep you up
and then they said everything you said
is good we appreciate
your
cooperation everything
but
you need to tell us something
that would put you in prison because
everything you said
america he told me is very liberal
country
and they need heart evidence
and then he said
you were in canada
you may have wanted to attack the cn
tower
the only problem i didn't know
what cn tower was
nor did i know where
and then he said like in toronto so and
then i said yes and it made sense to
everything
so
i said okay
and he confronted me with a phone
conversation i had in canada
i think it was on 22nd street 22nd
you know i was living with my friend
muhsim
because i didn't have an apartment this
was in montreal
correct
no i love material by the way it's
beautiful
the streets i never saw in my life a
street that is four 4 500
house
that's
you know you know europe like the
longest street in germany is 150 or 200
that's it
but i remember jean talon
what kind of street is that
like when you say oh i live in chat
along when my friend lives in
whoa you guys close no we are not close
so
it was 22nd
and
we were living and then
you know we like tea in mauritania at
least this culture we appreciate it
and it was i think 9 p.m
and it was really cold this is december
late december
and it was really cold and i really
liked it and this guy our neighbor he
wants to come over and drink tea and i
said could you please
uh
you know swing by the depanner you know
this is the paner it's
yes yeah could you please swing by and
get us some uh sugar tea yeah sugar i
think i didn't have sugar and then they
kept asking me they
they intercept this conversation what do
you mean when you say it in sugar and i
would say i meant sugar
wrong answer
so in this confession i told them that
tea and sugar are explosive
so and
so we just give them this nickname
that's where where i built the bomb
and
and they said okay why did you meet this
guy i said this guy helped me
so everybody had a role so now
everything
made sense to them because
all the guys around were bad people and
now they had a job so they gave money
we brought this
from
smugglers
and
i put everything in the confession and
they asked me to sign the confession and
i did sign the code
you know and
so
what was happening behind
the scene was
i was being
designated for death penalty
so and the guy who took
the case was
colonel couch u.s marines
and he was like a very decent person you
know
i mean he said he told them
this doesn't make sense to me he said he
denied everything and from one day to
the next he said
no more denial what's going on
then they wouldn't tell him anything and
then he made investigation on his own
and he found out i was heavily tortured
and then he resigned
he resigned
and
later on they give the case to a
uh colonel
maurice davis
they call him mo davis air force kernel
i know him we are friends now
and
he
so they said okay we need to put this
guy
on
lie detect
so because
the team who was interrogating him they
said they have
the gold nugget a confession
from a very bad guy
and the analyst said
bs he didn't do this
this is bs whatever he did to him we
don't know but this is what he said is
bs
so they came to me and they put me on
this
lie detector
i said guys i'm an engineer i cannot go
through this because i will tell the
truth
and then they said it doesn't matter you
have to
and then i was so scared because
now with the
with the confession i had the status of
of admitted
criminal
you know and i had i had the right to
eat i had the right to pray i had the
right to you know sleep for the first
time i didn't care what they did to me
after that you know
and then now i was so scared to go back
to torture when i deny everything
but they told me this was coming from
very high level people in the government
that i need
then i remember one of the question did
you ever plot or conspire to plot
against the us
and i said and canada and the guy told
me said i don't give a [ __ ] about canada
[Laughter]
i was like
good for you
in my head because i couldn't say
that you know you know and you know this
is like
very like
americans i'm sure you understand
because you're north american you know
this is
you know very americans because
because and i was so happy because i was
so upset with canada so upset
like if you tell me are you more upset
that there was or canada i would say
canada
because
i was a landed immigrant in canada
and
i was they scared me so much instead of
protecting me
they threw me under the bus
you know
you know they completely swallowed
everything that came from the cia fbi or
whatnot
and without doing their own
investigation and say you know what this
is a guy in our territory and this is a
guy
we
owe him
the protection and we need to know if
he's a bad guy we don't protect bad guys
but we need to understand his regard we
need to find out
and
so when he said that it was like the
only thing we agree on thank you
so
and then i passed the test
from like
a death penalty case
to someone who didn't do anything
you know because sorry let me get that
clear so you did the lie detector test
and what did it reveal it revealed that
your confession was false
everything i said that was incriminating
was false
have you ever perspired yeah have you
ever conspired did you ever talk to
anyone about harming the u.s never
nothing okay so so during the during the
lie detector test you told the truth
about everything
i see i see and so that was nullified
your confession
yes i denied everything and truthfully
so they took the
the test and they fought over it
they said they had
one of them insisted
to come next day or next week and to do
again the test
they did the test again and again i
passed it the test so
all of those tests are now
in my hands on my computer because my
lawyer gave them to me and they were
presented
at the court
at my court so and
so i was there
so the torch
effectively stopped
you know stopped
the end of 2000
early 2000 2004 there was no more torch
so that was so when you were you were in
the torture prison for two years if i
got that timeline right
uh
no no no okay the torch the intensive
torture was between
may
no was between june
of 2003
and early 2004
a little bit over half a year okay and
tell me again when you were when you
were brought to guantanamo bay tell me
when when you arrived there
i arrived august 5th
of 2003.
two two two not three yes
and
yes
so and uh
and so but what happened
that
they just didn't know what to do with me
so
and i was just there you know
and they wouldn't release me and they
wouldn't take me to try they wouldn't
release me because
they thought i was i witnessed so much i
saw so much and they didn't want me to
reveal it
at least that's my understanding of that
of my lawyers
and second they couldn't take me to any
trial because there was no crime to be
tried that was the conclusion of mo
davis and he wrote this in memorandum he
said there is no evidence
this guy did anything against us
and
on record he said that
so
you have to forward so then i started
making friendship with guards and
with interrogators you know i just start
to be
you know inmate
you know i start like you know the girls
are starting my friends and they
introduced me to american pop culture
music you know when they bring books i
they bar i borrow from them the books
did they did they realize at that point
did they treat you as if you were
innocent apart obviously they didn't
release you but your treatment radically
improved so did they believe you
your guards and so on
that's very hard to you know because
we didn't speak about
my innocence or my guilt
you know they
because it was like a taboo topic almost
i i didn't feel comfortable to talk
about it because
it's so
cliche for the 10th person to say i'm
innocent so i didn't i don't want to be
a cliche
absolutely not
i just want whatever you know whatever
i'm just
well you also must have been quite
relieved i would suspect since your days
have improved substantially
oh
you have no clue how relieved i was but
i was a mess
you know because
you know because i
i start hearing voices
and i start really to get very sick and
they put me on two medications paxon
and
the other clone opie
and then
and
so
like most of this time i was isolation
and then i begged them to take me out of
the isolation but they refused
then after i think two or three years i
didn't want to see people anymore
and to this day
you know jordan i don't
i don't feel comfortable around people
i always feel comfortable when i'm alone
you know because
how much time did you spend alone over
those those years
okay
2003 2016.
about 10 years mostly alone
how often would you see people
just sorry just
just the guards and the staff i see only
the guards and the staff
and what sort of cell were you in what
was it like
it was like
i think six by eight
no i don't think it's six because that's
i think it's four
four by six
don't want to pin myself but
what's maybe four by six feet four four
by
eight eight feet four by eight when was
there a bed in it
in the cell
yes it was like uh
it was like a metal you know a metal
sheet
you know
that's made in
to a bed
you can look it up you can look
guantanamo bay prison and then you will
see the cell
so you're alone for almost 10 years in
in that cell
and so how did it come to be that you
got legal representation and were able
to start to
free yourself
some uk citizen
went to court because they were with us
and they had good lawyers
then they made it all the way to the
supreme court
and then they
and then they they won the right to be
uh
to challenge their detention
and
i i was not aware of this because i had
no right
even to contact anyone
but the family of that's the
advantage of a free country so uk is a
free country so their families they
fought
very much for everyone and
so i had all of a sudden i i benefited
from these uk citizens
because the right was given to everyone
and in 2005 mid-2005 i met my lawyers
for the first time i met
nancy hollande and sylvia royce
they came to me
they
and then
i saw them as a window and i started to
write my story my memo my memoir
so what did you think when you when a
lawyer showed up
i was so happy you know
and i remember the first time they came
to me i sat on a chair like this
with a desk in front of me
you know the
it was like one of the standard
interrogation room and then i stood up
and then i started to say hi
but i couldn't i wouldn't move because i
was bolted
but they couldn't see the the the chain
and they were like
sitting there because they were brief
that
detainees are dangerous people
so and they were scared
and then
i was very happy honestly
you know and how long did it take your
lawyers to
understand your story and i presume
believe you
yes very long very long because
uh the accused is innocent until proven
guilty only your mother believed this
so
people at large and i'm sure you you
understand these people
perceive
the accused as
well it would be very hard for someone
to believe that you had spent that long
in guantanamo bay and weren't guilty of
something i mean because they would have
to question the validity of the entire
system and that's not an easy thing to
do
and that's probably even a harder thing
to do if you are from a country where
rule of law is the norm
correct
correct yes yes
absolutely you know
and
i mean i can't say more than what you
said
and i was like
okay how can i explain to them
and then they were very shocked when the
government when they first
compelled the government to show them
the government showed them the
confession he confessed
and then they were very upset with him
he said why you were lying to us and so
and i was like oh my the government only
showed them i confess they didn't show
them i was torsor
did they show them the lie detector
results
much later on because
the government holds all the cars and
then they show
only the things they want to show you
know
and
you know like
the democracy and the rule of law is
promised
that the three branches of the
government cooperate with each other
so
and
the the the
the executive power has so much power
over judiciary
and the parliament because only the
executive power has weapons
has
violence could uh could use violence
because a judge can only tell you you're
right you can't go home but the judge
doesn't have the key to open the cell
and let you go home so the
the executive power
has
to cooperate and respect the judiciary
by and large this function in
democracies but in the case of
guantanamo bay the
executive power completely showed
[Music]
a great deal of contempt
toward court system
so how did your lawyers
free you how did that happen
look
this is not easy because they had to
prove that i was innocent
that was like mission impossible
because they have to show the government
i'm innocent it's not the burden it's
not of the government because
this is and i say this very frankly and
very straight
the problem with the crime they call
terrorism
is that
it's very political very politicized
and especially in my part of the world i
can speak to that it's used to oppress
peaceful mostly peaceful political
descent
and to crush them
and to uh people who don't like just to
put them in a prison because they could
be your political rivals unfortunately
this playbook of the dictatorial regime
the middle east and authoritarian
regimes was copied in guantanamo bay and
they just say you're terrorists because
when someone says you're terrorist
everything could be done against you
and there is no definition and i have
big problem with that i don't think that
philosophically in a democracy terrorism
should be a crime terrorism in a
democracy cannot be a crime because one
it's not clearly defined
terrorists in canada are not terrorists
in egypt
tourists in egypt are not terrorists in
saudi arabia saudi arabias in palestine
and israel etc etc but a murderer is a
murderer because
same thing in canada
in
the u.s in mauritania if you kill
someone
that's a crime
and it's can be proven very easily
but you you could be a terrorist in
egypt and as soon as you get to canada
you're a good citizen
you know
and second it's used for uh political
purposes and political uh
oppression
and it's used to uh
or i need to bail out so and it's used
to uh
to to
punish
people a mass i can give you an example
uh
just few months ago
the houthi in yemen were a terrorist
group
and then now they are not tourist group
anymore
what kind of
what kind of justice is that
you know
so how did your lawyers prove that to
the to the satisfaction of the people
who could release you that you should be
released
they took me
to uh
so
we fought to go to the court system so i
was intimidated i was threatened but i
said i'm going to go in 2009 we
succeeded
to fi to to be heard by the late george
robertson
i mean uh
robertson judge robertson
and
he
he ordered my release
in 2010 so he heard us in late 2009
ordered my list in 2000 and he said
there is no evidence to hold this guy
and the government refused
and then they uh
they appealed the appeal hung
you know
and
i so my book was published after a very
big fight
and then after the publishing of my book
the government said they want to review
my case they reviewed my case they said
i'm no threat to the u.s
in 2016. july of 2016
and in october of 2016 they said i can't
go home
end of story
now a movie was made out of that book as
well
a movie the mauritanian
please
go and watch the movie and make up your
own mind
and
it's
pretty accurate
and
there is no hero in the movie just like
a bunch of people
and
it shows like
just you know the weakness of human
beings your attitude towards all of this
now
total forgiveness
because i believe in reconciliation
i believe that our life is too short to
hold grudges
and to wage wars because we need each
other
you know my country needs the united
states
and the united states could
need my country and we need to be
brothers and sisters
and we need to cooperate and make our
world a better place and i'm starting by
honestly and earnestly say that i hold
no grudge against anyone and i'm ready
to cooperate with anyone regardless of
their religion their background their
ideological political ideology
and why did you come to that decision
because of the diaper story i told you
one of the cia put me in a diaper in
diapers
and i faced okay okay i want to be a
better person
and you hung on to that through the time
that you were in guantanamo bay
absolutely i couldn't
honestly express it because people could
say ah he's just scared but now i'm a
free man
i could say it and i'm inviting everyone
i met in guatemala to come to me
some people came to me and with the
drunk tea they stayed at my home one of
the guards
steve wood he came to me three times and
i hosted him in my humble and why did he
come to see you
do you think we became friends we became
good friends you know he's the godfather
of my child i'm the godfather of his
daughter
and
we just we just
we just won
we just want to be friends and to show
everyone that
you know peace can be made we don't need
to hold grudges
is there anything else you want to say
i would like to say i'm so honored to be
on your show
and i thank you so much to give me your
platform
and allow me to share my story with your
audience
well thank you for walking through it
i'm i'm sure that's far from pleasant
to do that and
you have no clue yes
thank god
for that
muhammadu it was it was very good of you
to talk with me i wish you the best so
much
and i please take care of yourself and
get healthy
most important thing
much appreciated
thank
[Music]
you